this is a hugely historic moment
vladimir putin in one move with this war
here in ukraine has done the exact
opposite of what he intended to do he's
effectively enabling the expansion of
nato the finnish president and prime
minister have given their verdict on
whether or not a country that has been
historically neutral since the end of
the second world war should effectively
pick sides and side with the nato
alliance and by saying that they agree
that that is what the country should do
it paves the way for parliament and the
government to make their decision as
well which ultimately will lead to a
formal application of nato membership
being made perhaps within the next few
days let me just read a bit from the
statement where the two leaders set out
their deliberations saying how they have
been thinking and discussing this
internally and also with nato allies
over the spring it's a huge monumental
change in foreign policy and they say
that their their view on nato membership
is that it would it would strengthen
finland's security as a member of nato
finland would strengthen the entire
defense alliance
and it's that they say ultimately
finland must apply for nato membership
without delay we hope that the national
steps still needed to make this decision
will be taken rapidly within the next
few days now this comes as finland's
neighbor sweden is also thinking about
taking the same step and a decision from
sweden is also expected imminently both
countries incredibly alarmed by the fact
that russia has chosen to invade ukraine
also alarmed by russia's rhetoric in
reach in recent months saying that no
other country can join nato saying that
anything that that they do and this is
what the finnish
president said yesterday is actually a
direct consequence of russia's actions
with the finnish president effectively
telling vladimir putin to look in the
mirror and realize that he that this his
actions russia's actions is the cause of
what is happening in finland and also
potentially in sweden